This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全去坦诚交流的对话，但在这里，你是在和一位深谙此道的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着因为你有这种能力，你就必须去这样做，快来收听。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。快来收听《2%》。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的好姐妹们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾往昔》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时期的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody, welcome back to this show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, whatever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代一样。84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾往昔》。大家好，欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪一个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听我们新的一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析我们20多岁时的心理。
First and foremost, I want to thank you all so much for the overwhelming love and soul. support you have had for my book, Person in Progress, as I am recording this, the book has been out for just under a week and the messages and DMs I've received, the pictures from people who have found it in Germany, in Singapore, in New York, in Romania, has truly made every single moment since so unbelievably special. You know, you put a lot of love. into a book and this being my first one, I have to admit, I wasn't really sure how it was going to turn out. I'm, you know, I will happily admit that I was very, very afraid and the day it came out was actually very anticlimactic, but also quite stressful. So hearing from you all,
首先，我非常感谢大家对我的书《成长中的人》（Person in Progress）表现出的排山倒海般的喜爱与精神支持。当我录制这期节目时，这本书上市刚刚不到一周，我收到了许多私信和私聊截图，看到人们在德国、新加坡、纽约、罗马尼亚找到这本书的照片，真的让此后的每一个时刻都变得如此难以置信的特别。你知道，你倾注了大量的爱
now that it's out in the world, seeing you guys with your copies, it really has been the best part of this and it's made it also just so worth it. Um, it's made it like a thing of dreams really it's just it's unbelievable if you still haven't gotten a copy it is available wherever you get your books on audible kindle in hard copy from a bookstore it is the easiest and most direct way to support me in the podcast so i appreciate every single one of you who has bought it reviewed it spoken about it with friends colleagues family it truly does all add up now to the episode I know we were just speaking about something, you know, remarkably happy and positive, but this episode is tackling something that's somewhat adjacent, maybe, but also a bit different.
在一本书上，而且这是我的第一本书，我必须承认，我真的不确定它会反响如何。我，你知道，我很高兴地承认，我当时非常非常害怕，它出版的那天其实非常平淡，但也相当紧张。所以听到你们所有人，
It's something a lot of us struggle with silently, and that is an inability to be happy with what we have. That sense that something is always missing, the itch that won't go away. You know, you get the job, and then you want a promotion. You move into a new house, and then suddenly you're looking for something. even better or thinking about what's not right with it. You get into a relationship and yet there's still that lingering thought, is there something better out there for me? Is this it? If you are haunted by this type of thinking, you've probably found that it applies to nearly everything in your life. So many of us live in this in-between space, right? This space between where we are and where we think
现在它已经面世了，看到你们拿着书的合影，这真的是这段经历中最棒的部分，也让这一切变得如此值得。嗯，这真的像是一个梦想成真，简直是难以置信。如果你还没有买一本，它在任何能买到书的地方都有售，无论是在Audible、Kindle还是实体书店的纸质书。这是支持我和这个播客最简单、最直接的方式，所以我感谢每一个购买过它、评价过它、与朋友、同事、家人讨论过它的朋友，这些真的都汇聚成了巨大的力量。现在回到这期节目。我知道我们刚才还在谈论一件，你知道的，非常开心和积极的事情，但这期节目要探讨的是一个与之有点类似，但又有些许不同的主题。
we should be. And that gap, it often feels like failure. Even if we've achieved so much, we end up living by this more, more, more mentality I've spoken about before. You know, once we have what we want, all we can think about is what we don't, meaning the bar is always being raised, we always want more, we never appreciate how far we've come. So we repeatedly undervalue our progress and our happiness is the price we pay. I think this is also particularly compounded by the upheaval of being in our 20s where it feels like we're in competition with everyone around us. What do they have that I don't? Why do they seem so much happier? Why does their life seem more together? How can I have that? How can I be like them? How can I feel more
这是我们许多人都在默默挣扎的事情，那就是无法对我们所拥有的感到快乐。那种总觉得少了点什么的感觉，那种挥之不去的痒。你知道的，你找到了工作，然后你又想要升职。你搬进了新房子，然后突然间你又在寻找更好的东西，或者开始琢磨它哪里还不够完美。你谈了恋爱，然而心里依然挥之不去那个念头：外面是不是有更好的人在等着我？难道就这样了吗？如果你一直被这种想法所困扰，你可能会发现它几乎适用于你生活中的方方面面。我们有那么多人生活在这个进退维谷的空间里，对吧？这个介于我们现在所在的位置和我们认为
secure? The answer is we will never feel secure if we don't first understand. We don't first understand what is driving this constant sense of dissatisfaction. And you know what? The solution? It's more than just gratitude. It's something that goes a whole lot deeper. It's probably going to surprise a few of you actually. So my friends, I am excited to explore this psychology with you.
我们应该在的位置之间的空间。而这种差距，往往让人感觉像是一种失败。即使我们已经取得了那么多的成就，我们最终还是落入了那种“多多益善”的心态，我以前也谈过这一点。你知道，一旦我们得到了想要的，我们满脑子想的都是我们还没有得到的，这意味着标准总是在提高，我们总是想要更多，我们从来不感激自己已经走了多远。因此，我们反复低估了自己的进步，而我们的幸福就是我们付出的代价。我认为，这在20多岁生活的动荡中尤为严重，在这个时期，我们感觉自己好像在和周围的每一个人竞争。他们有什么是我没有的？为什么他们看起来那么快乐？为什么他们的生活看起来比我更有条理？我怎么才能拥有那种生活？我怎么才能像他们一样？我怎么才能感到更加
Some of you may also know I have a podcast called Mantra. And we did a more philosophical take on this episode over there. If you finish this and you want more, mantra is like the psychology of your 20s soulful sister, part meditation, part inspirational. Each week we give you a new mantra to focus your attention on for the week ahead. Like some of the recent ones we've done are I release the need to do it all. I trust myself to make the best decision with what I know now. So many more, it's just like the most fabulous way to start your week.
安全感？答案是：如果我们不首先去理解，我们就永远不会感到安全。我们如果不首先弄清楚是什么在驱动这种持续的失落感和不满足感。你知道吗？解决办法不仅仅是感恩。它是比那更深层次的东西。其实这可能会让你们中的一些人感到惊讶。所以朋友们，我很高兴能和大家一起探索这种心理。
So don't forget to check it out after that. But without further ado, let's talk about why we never seem to be happy with what we have. I want to explain the feeling of never being happy with what we have first here, because I really want to articulate how this feels in your body, in your thoughts, how it looks in your day-to-day life, because if you haven't already suspected, this feeling sounds a lot like, you know, good old-fashioned depression. But it is different. this contentment, happiness, treadmill, as I call it, this constant pursuit of more, it's not a
你们中的有些人可能也知道，我有一个叫做Mantra的播客。我们在那里对这一期节目进行了更具哲学意味的探讨。如果你听完了这期节目还想听更多，Mantra就像是《20多岁心理学》的灵魂姊妹，集冥想与励志于一体。每周我们都会为你提供一个新的心咒，让你把注意力集中在接下来的这一周上。比如我们最近做过的一些心咒：我释放了必须面面俱到的需求。我相信自己能根据目前已知的信息做出最好的决定。还有很多很多，这简直是以最美妙的方式开启你一周的绝佳途径。
clinical label. Not being happy with what you have is not really something that you could be diagnosed with in the way that you could be diagnosed with a mental health disorder. But it may be a symptom of something larger. So to be diagnosed with a major depressive disorder, you do have to meet a number of specific criteria or exhibit a number of symptoms, a lack of satisfaction with what we have is probably going to contribute to a number of these, but it's not a symptom on its own. Depression, you know, it can make even the most remarkable moments bland because of a deeper
所以别忘了在听完之后去看看。但闲话少说，让我们来聊聊为什么我们似乎永远对拥有的东西感到不满足。我想首先在这里解释一下“永远对拥有的一切不满意”这种感觉，因为我真的很想阐述这种感觉在你的身体里、在你的思绪中、在你的日常生活中是如何体现的，因为如果你还没有猜到的话听起来，这种感觉很像，你知道的，老派的抑郁症。但其实并非如此。这种满足感、幸福感的“跑步机”，正如我所称的那样，这种对更多的不断追逐，它并不是一个
number of reactions and interactions going on below the surface. So an inability to be happy with what you have may be symptomatic of that, but you can also struggle with this and constantly crave more success, more accolades, more friends, more of whatever it is, whilst not being depressed, whilst still feeling generally kind of happy, still being able to concentrate, not suffering from insomnia, fatigue, these kinds of things. The problem really occurs when this spirals and the dissatisfaction is all you seem to be able to focus on all day, every day. The losses, the failures, they become the fixation for you.
临床标签。对现状不满意并不是那种你可以被诊断出来的病症，就像你可以被诊断出患有心理健康障碍那样。但它可能是某种更大问题的症状。因此，要被诊断为重度抑郁症，你必须满足许多特定的标准或表现出许多症状，对现状缺乏满意度可能会导致其中的许多表现，但它本身并不是一个症状。抑郁症，你知道的，它甚至能让最卓越的时刻变得索然无味，因为在表象之下有更深层的
So there is this theory called the 50-50 principle, which essentially suggests that for every emotion or positive experience we have, there will be an equal experience or emotion that will be negative. So you get a promotion, your car gets towed. You get a free coffee, you stop your toe. You go on a great first date, you forget about your really expensive electricity bill. quickly reflect on your last week for me here. I feel like that balance is pretty accurate.
一系列反应和相互作用在发生。因此，无法对你所拥有的感到快乐可能是这种状况的症状，但你也可以一边与此挣扎并不断渴望更多的成功、更多的赞誉、更多的朋友、更多无论什么东西，一边并没有抑郁，同时总体上仍然感到某种程度的快乐，依然能够集中注意力，没有遭受失眠、疲劳这些问题的困扰。真正的问题出现在当这种情绪陷入恶性循环，而这种不满似乎成了你整天、每天唯一能专注于的事情。那些损失、那些失败，成了你挥之不去的执念。
Sometimes you have months that are more negative. Sometimes it makes up for it and you have months that are more positive. But it always comes back to the 50-50. When we are struggling with being happy with what we have, this theory would essentially suggest that it's not because nothing good or amazing is happening, but that we're focusing too much on the negative experience that are always going to occur. Or we forget to appreciate what is good and therefore we start seeing things that are actually positive as a letdown because perhaps our expectations for the 50% that is good in our life is just too high.
因此，有一个叫做50-50原则的理论，它本质上表明，对于我们所经历的每一个情绪或积极体验，都会有一个同等程度的消极体验或情绪与之对应。所以，你升职了，但你的车被拖走了。你得到了一杯免费咖啡，但你的脚趾踢到了。你进行了一次很棒的第一次约会，但你却把那张昂贵得离谱的电费单给忘了。请在这里为我快速反思一下你过去一周的生活。我觉得这个平衡点相当准确。
So returning to what I was saying before, what does this headspace of never being happy with what we have look like? Well, firstly, often what it's going to manifest as is obsessive future planning and a real difficulty staying present. This is also known as when, then thinking. So when I get this, then I'll be happy. When I get the job, when I get the partner, when I get the shiny new object, this has another name. It's called the arrival fallacy. When I arrive at this arbitrary point, I will be static.
有时你会遇到比较消极的月份。有时它会弥补回来，你会遇到比较积极的月份。但它总是会回到50-50的平衡状态。当我们纠结于如何对现有的生活感到满足时，这个理论本质上表明，并不是因为没有什么美好或惊艳的事情发生，而是因为我们把太多的注意力集中在了那些必然会发生的消极体验上。或者我们忘记了去欣赏美好的事物，因此我们开始把实际上很积极的事情看作是一种让人失望的事情，这或许是因为我们对生活中那50%的好事的期望实在太高了。
My life will make sense. That point, of course, though, always keeps moving. You know, how many of us are constantly waiting for something and waiting so intently, we kind of forget that the chapter where now is just as sweet, it's just as important. Sometimes you really have to question, like, what is enough for me? What is this secret, you know, secret doorway that I will one day walk through that will make me finally happy? objectively when we're experiencing a severe lack of basic needs getting certain things like job security more income stable shelter you know that's certainly going to increase our happiness levels
所以回到我刚才所说的话，这种“永远对拥有的一切不满意”的心态究竟是什么样子的呢？首先，它通常表现为对未来的强迫性规划，并且很难活在当下。这也被称为“当……时，我就会……”的思维模式。所以，当我得到这个时，我就会快乐。当我得到这份工作时，当我找到伴侣时，当我得到闪亮的新物件时，这还有另一个名字。它叫做“抵达谬误”。当我到达这个随意的节点时，我就会欣喜若狂。
the happiness jump between having very little to having enough to sustain you and then having enough to be comfortable those jumps are very very large but once you are comfortable from there we really don't realize how minor and incremental the change to our happiness level will be, but we place so much pressure on what are actually really small changes to transform our lives when we already have, you know, actually so much. You may also find that, you know, when you do achieve the big things that you previously told yourself would be enough for you, you still feel quite empty. I think this is actually the biggest indicator of the mall.
我的生活就会变得有意义。然而，那个节点当然总是不断在移动。你知道，我们中有多少人一直在等待着什么，并且如此急切地等待着，以至于我们有点忘记了“当下”这一章节同样美好，同样重要。有时候你真的不得不问自己，比如，什么对我来说才算足够？什么是我有一天会穿过的那个秘密的、能够让我最终快乐的秘密之门？客观地说，当我们经历严重的缺乏基本需求时，比如获得工作安全感、更多的收入、稳定的住所，你知道，这肯定会提高我们的幸福水平。
you say, you know, when I graduate from university, then my life is going to start and then you walk across the stage, nothing really changes. You finally get into the relationship, but you find that, you know, even the most perfect person isn't going to eliminate all other struggles in your life. Another indicator that you're not happy with what you have, envy or jealousy towards the people you perceive have at all. And with that, probably also some frustration and self-hatred. You know, that heavy feeling in your body, that battle between, you know, feeling envious of someone else and then trying to rein it in and control your ego and then feeling envious and being like, why am I thinking this way? I'm such a bad person, but you can't stop it and you feel guilty.
从一无所有到勉强维持温饱，再到丰衣足食，这之间的幸福感跨越是非常非常巨大的。但一旦你感到舒适之后，从那以后，我们真的意识不到幸福感的改变会有多么微小和渐进，然而我们却把巨大的压力寄托在那些实际上非常小的改变上，指望它们能彻底改变我们的生活，而实际上我们已经拥有了，你知道的，其实非常多。你可能还会发现，当你真正实现了以前告诉自己就足够的大事时，你仍然会感到相当空虚。我认为这其实是“更多”心态的最大指标。
It's just a constant spiral. Persistent restlessness. Now, this can manifest in a lot of things, frequent job or relationships. relationship hopping, even constantly moving cities, countries, anything to find the place, the person, the thing that could finally, you know, change everything for you. This is a common thing we see in our 20s, right? Honestly, I'm guilty of it. I moved to Sydney after a breakup because I thought it would change my life. And trust me, it did not have that immediate effect. In fact, it probably made it harder in the first year. The geographic cure. Once I move to this place, I'll be happy.
你说，你知道，当我从大学毕业时，我的生活就要开始了，然后你走上了毕业典礼的舞台，却发现其实什么都没有改变。你终于谈上了恋爱，但你发现，你知道，即使是最完美的人也无法消除你生活中的所有其他挣扎。另一个表明你对现状不满的指标是，对那些你认为拥有一切的人产生嫉妒或羡慕。伴随而来的，可能还有一些挫败感和自我厌恶。你知道，身体里那种沉重的感受，在对别人感到嫉妒、然后试图克制并控制自己的小我之间进行拉扯，接着又感到嫉妒并想：我为什么会这样想？我真是个糟糕的人，但你又停不下来，并且感到内疚。
If I just pick up everything and move cities, my whole life will change and I'll forget about all these issues. The geographic cure is a myth. To offer you some evidence of this, in one study in 2012, the researcher David Kahnman asked a group of individuals living in one part of the US, specifically the Midwest, do you think people living in Southern California are happier? The majority of them were like, yeah, of course they are. It's beautiful, it's sunny. Who wouldn't be happier there? He then asked, do you think you'd be happier if you moved there? A majority of them said, yes, they would. But when he actually compared life satisfaction scores between the two cities, he found that they were nearly identical.
这简直就是一个无休止的恶性循环。持续的不安。现在，这可以表现在很多事情上，频繁地换工作或谈恋爱。频繁更换伴侣，甚至不断搬去不同的城市、不同的国家，只要能找到那个地方、那个人、那个最终能，你知道，改变你一切的东西就行。这是我们在20多岁时常见的一种现象，对吧？老实说，我自己也难辞其咎。我在经历了一次分手后搬到了悉尼，因为我以为这会改变我的生活。相信我，它并没有产生那种立竿见影的效果。事实上，它可能让我在第一年过得更加艰难。地理上的治愈。一旦我搬到了这个地方，我就会快乐。
So all these individuals in the Midwest, and you could replace the Midwest with really any country, any city, there's always going to be this beautiful, romanticized city that we think when we move to, it will change our lives and everyone there is happy and thriving. But what he found was that actually it doesn't really change much. It's nearly identical. Location isn't the thing that it's going to change your life. life. It's the perception of your life or the perception of the place that does that. Another study from 2016, this time in the UK, found something very similar, but it also found
所以，中西部地区的这些人，你可以把中西部换成任何一个国家、任何一座城市，总会有这样一个美丽而浪漫的城市让我们心生向往，觉得只要搬过去，生活就会发生翻天覆地的变化，那里的每个人都会幸福美满、蒸蒸日上。但他发现，实际情况并没有改变多少。简直一模一样。地理位置并不是那个能改变你生活的东西。对生活的感知或者对那个地方的看法才是起决定作用的。2016年的另一项研究，这一次是在英国，得出了非常相似的结论，但它还发现
that moving cities actually makes you more stressed, more detached, more lonely. So a warning to anyone in their 20s right now, I'm talking to you, if you think a sudden move is going to finally make you happier. The story is a lot more complex. A few other signs here that you're struggling to find happiness with what you have. No matter how much you receive or achieve, you catastrophize small setbacks. You can be quite impulsive, especially with money. You overconsume lifestyle content that is idealistic and romanticized. You may spend more time online shopping or scrolling dating apps,
搬到不同的城市实际上会让你感到压力更大、更疏离、更孤独。因此，给现在所有20代年轻人提个醒，我说的就是你们，如果你觉得突然搬家最终能让你更开心，那就大错特错了。事情要复杂得多。这里还有其他一些迹象，表明你在为拥有的一切寻找幸福时感到了挣扎。无论你得到或取得了多少成就，你都会把小挫折灾难化。你可能会相当冲动，尤其是在金钱方面。你过度消费理想化和浪漫化的生活方式内容。你可能会花更多时间在网上购物或刷约会软件上，
and your mood is seemingly linked to your external accomplishments and what you have rather than your internal sense of satisfaction. So if this sounds like you, I want to explain why this may be happening. Because it can be seriously confronting, especially when we start to perhaps realize, wait, you know, what would I need to finally be content? And if I don't get that, will I ever be happy? Is there a final destination, a final spot I wish to be? Does that even exist? So essentially, when we have this more, more mindset, when we can't be happy with what we have,
而你的情绪似乎与你的外部成就以及你所拥有的东西息息相关，而不是源于你内心的满足感。所以，如果这听起来很像你，我想解释一下这背后的原因。因为这可能会带来严重的心理冲击，尤其是当我们开始意识到：等等，我到底需要什么才能最终感到满足？如果我得不到那些，我会快乐吗？是否存在终点站，是否存在我希望抵达的终极地点？那真的存在吗？本质上，当我们拥有这种“多多益善”的心态，当我们对现有的东西无法感到满足时，
What is occurring is something called hedonic adaptation. It's also called the hiddenism treadmill. So this was first given a name in the 1970s by two Canadian researchers, Brickman and Campbell. And what they found is that humans, no matter what's happening in their life, you know, they could win a Grammy. They could marry the love of their life. They could also lose the love of their life. It could lose everything. we will still typically return to a fairly stable baseline level of happiness that seems to be largely predetermined,
正在发生的一种现象叫做享乐适应。它也被称为享乐水车。这个词在20世纪70年代由两位加拿大研究人员布里克曼和坎贝尔首次提出。他们发现，无论人类生活中发生什么——你知道的，他们可能赢得格莱美奖，他们可能与一生挚爱结婚，他们也可能失去一生挚爱，可能失去一切——我们通常仍然会回到一个相当稳定、似乎在很大程度上是预先决定的基准幸福水平，
regardless of what is happening around us. Now this is specifically the case, or especially the case I should say, with really happy, positive events. You know, you land your dream job, but the ecstasy of that doesn't last that long. You know, it's not long until you start to notice the downsides or you get into a relationship, and it's amazing and thrilling until the novelty wears off and then you kind of return back to that stable level. This is basically our brain's way of maintaining emotional balance, but it also means that we rarely feel happy and satisfied for long. The big things we think will change our life.
无论我们周围正在发生什么。这种情况尤为明显，或者我应该说，在非常快乐、积极的事件中尤其明显。你知道的，你找到了梦想的工作，但那种狂喜并不会持续太久。用不了多久，你就会开始注意到它的缺点，或者你进入了一段恋爱关系，它起初是那么美妙和令人兴奋，直到新鲜感消退，然后你就会不知不觉地回到那个稳定的水平。这基本上是大脑保持情感平衡的一种方式，但这也意味着我们很少能长时间感到快乐和满足。我们以为会改变生活的那些大事，
They actually don't end up changing that much in the long term, but because we expect that they will, we also equally feel even more let down. The psychologist Sonia Lubamuski, she wrote the book, The Myth of Happiness, she added onto this research and she discovered that only around 10% of our happiness comes from external circumstances. Only 10%. Around 40% comes from attitude and your intentional mindset. 50% is actually genetically determined.
从长远来看其实并没有改变多少，但正因为我们对它们抱有期望，所以当现实不如预期时，我们也会感到加倍的失落。心理学家索尼亚·柳博米尔斯基在她的著作《幸福的迷思》中对这项研究进行了补充，她发现我们大约只有10%的幸福感来自外部环境。只有10%。大约40%来自态度和你的主观心态。而50%其实是由基因决定的。
Yet that 10%, that is where we put most of our focus on. We think if I just had this one more thing, I'd finally feel whole. If I just achieve this, I'd finally be happy. Once we get to it, we recalibrate. The happiness we expect it doesn't last. That's hedonic adaptation at work. We're always resetting the bar. Basically, what I'm trying to say through this is it's not you.
然而，那10%正是我们投入最多精力的部分。我们认为，只要再多拥有这么一样东西，我终于就能感到完整了。只要我实现了这个目标，我终于就能快乐了。一旦我们达到了目标，我们就会重新校准。我们期待的幸福并不会持久。这就是享乐适应在起作用。我们总是在不断重置标准。基本上，我想通过这些表达的是：这不是你的问题，
It's your human blueprint trying to kind of almost humble us, it seems. Our brain chemistry also plays a major role. Of course, if we're going to talk about happiness, at some stage, we're going to talk about dopamine. Dopamine, it's not just the happiness chemical, it's the neurotransmitter associated with motivation, reward, and pleasure. But here's the thing that most of us don't know about dopamine. And I don't think I even ended up learning about this until I was in my third year of studying psychology.
而是你的基因蓝图似乎在试图让我们放低姿态。我们的脑化学成分也发挥了重要作用。当然，如果我们谈论幸福，在某个阶段我们肯定会谈到多巴胺。多巴胺不仅是“快乐化学物质”，它还是与动机、奖励和愉悦感相关的神经递质。但大多数人不了解多巴胺的是：我觉得直到我读心理学大三时我才知道这一点，
Your dopamine doesn't spike when you get the reward, but in anticipation of it. I was always told, you know, when you eat a chocolate bar, it makes you happy, when you do this, it makes you happy. It's the anticipation of it that makes you feel happy. And the relief of finally getting it. So when you're fantasizing about the next big thing, your brain floods with dopamine. You feel excited. You feel hopeful. You feel alive.
你的多巴胺并不是在获得奖励时激增，而是在期待奖励的过程中激增。我过去常听人说，当你吃巧克力棒时，它会让你快乐，当你做这个时，它会让你快乐。其实是那种期待感让你感到快乐，还有最终获得它的解脱感。所以，当你幻想着下一件大事时，你的大脑会涌入多巴胺。你会感到兴奋。你会感到充满希望。你会觉得自己充满了活力。
You know, think about the excitement before a first date or a big overseas trip. But once you actually get it, the dopamine drop off from. that leaves you feeling flat, even disappointed. It's why people, you know, they go to their dream destinations, they go to Paris, they go to Thailand, they go to Rome, and they're like, I'm kind of disappointed. It's not what my expectations were. Or their wedding day or a big milestone, you know, maybe they don't end up leaving that feeling as happy as they thought they would. But this explains why we feel addicted to the act of setting very huge goals, but not necessarily fulfilled when we get the thing. We're not actually addicted
你知道的，想想初次约会或一次盛大的海外旅行之前的兴奋感。但一旦你真正得到了它，多巴胺的随之骤降会让你感到平淡，甚至失望。这就是为什么人们去他们的梦想目的地——他们去巴黎，他们去泰国，他们去罗马，然后他们会觉得：有点失望，这和我想象的不一样。或者他们的婚礼或一个大里程碑，你知道的，也许他们最终离开时的幸福感并没有想象中那么高。但这解释了为什么我们对设定宏大目标的行为上瘾，但在达成目标时却不一定感到充实。我们上瘾的其实不是
to achievement. We're addicted to the feeling of almost. This can lead to something I call a success hangover. It's also known as gold medal syndrome for a more formal name you'd find in a psychology textbook. Gold medal syndrome, of course, named after Olympians who work their entire freaking lives for one moment for a gold medal. And then they get it. And they're like, oh, this is it? This is all I ever wanted. Now what? What do I do after this? Every single, you know, the Olympics were, when I'm recording this last year, every single time the Olympics are on, I'm always reminded of this. And I always see people who have worked probably since they were three, four years old, finally achieve their dreams. And I'm like,
成就本身。我们上瘾的是“差一点就成功”的感觉。这可能会导致一种我称之为“成功宿醉”的现象。在心理学教科书里，它还有一个更正式的名字，叫做“金牌得主综合征”。金牌综合征，当然是以那些为了获得一块金牌而拼尽一生、付出全部努力的奥运选手命名的。然后他们得到了金牌。他们却说：“啊，这就是全部吗？这就是我一直想要的全部吗？接下来呢？我接下来该做什么？”每一届——你知道的，我录制节目时正值去年的奥运会——每当奥运会举办时，我总会被提醒这一点。我总是看到那些可能从三四岁起就开始努力、最终实现梦想的人，然后我就会想：
oh my God, that's when the real, that's when the real work begins. That's when the real struggle happens because now you have to redefine yourself after getting everything you've ever wanted, but also perhaps realizing, you know, you had to fantasize about how amazing it would be in order to get to this place. It might not meet those expectations. And you know what? You don't have to win a gold medal to experience this. Let me give you one final explanation for why we are never happy with what we have. And we kind of talked about it before, but it's something. called the negativity bias. So this is a cognitive bias that we have as humans in which we constantly
哦天哪，这才是真正的考验开始的时候，这才是真正的挣扎发生的时候，因为现在你必须在得到你一直想要的一切之后重新定义自己，同时也可能意识到：为了来到这个地方，你不得不去幻想它是多么的不可思议，而现实可能无法达到那些期望。你知道吗？你不需要赢得金牌就能体验到这种感受。让我给出最后一个解释，解释为什么我们永远对自己拥有的东西不满意。我们之前其实也讨论过，但它被称为“消极偏差”。这是人类拥有的一种认知偏差，我们会不断地
focus on the negative parts of life. Some of us more than others, if you're quite pessimistic, you'd also be doing this. Even optimism doesn't necessarily protect us from this. Yes, there are some people who are, you know, crazily optimistic and who perhaps don't see the world in a negative light. Those people are quite rare. Most of us will find that we spend a lot more time thinking about the little frustrations, the things that went wrong, the things that are stressing us out, then the things that are making us feel joyful, than the things that we are happy and proud of, then the things that make our life feel quite meaningful. I know I do this. I literally released a book a week ago and you know what I spent the whole morning thinking of?
关注生活中的负面部分。有些人比其他人更严重，如果你非常悲观，你也会这样做。即使是乐观主义者也不一定能免受这种影响。是的，有些人非常乐观，可能不会以消极的眼光看待世界。这样的人相当罕见。我们大多数人都会发现，我们花在思考那些小挫折、出错的事情、让我们感到压力的事情上的时间，要远远多于那些让我们感到快乐的事情，多于那些让我们感到幸福和骄傲的事情，多于那些让我们的生活觉得相当有意义的事情。我知道我就会这样做。我一周前刚刚出版了一本书，你知道我整个早上都在想什么吗？
Oh my God, I'm so busy. I have so many chores, this and that. You know, the microphone wasn't working this morning. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And it's all I thought about. And I realized, oh my goodness. Like, this negativity bias is exhausting. But it's also something that we can sometimes struggle to manage because it's how we're hardwired to think. Let's talk about this from a survival perspective.
“哦天哪，我太忙了。我有太多的杂务，这个那个。”你知道的，今天早上麦克风坏了。巴拉巴拉巴拉。这就是我脑子里想的全部。我意识到，哦天哪。这种消极偏差太让人筋疲力尽了。但这也是我们有时难以应对的事情，因为这是我们根深蒂固的思维方式。让我们从生存的角度来谈谈这一点。
Back in the day, we're roaming the Sahara, we're roaming the mountains, the jungle. You need to focus more on what is potentially threatening, dangerous, scary if you want to survive, then watching the sunset, looking at the beautiful berries, the beautiful flowers, the beautiful butterflies. In a modern society, though, that's no longer as protective as it was back then, now it's actually just, I'm just going to say it, it's a letdown. It's so annoying. So annoying. You know, when it comes to never being happy with what we have, We can also look at things like comparison. We can look at things like boredom.
过去的日子里，我们在撒哈拉沙漠游荡，我们在山脉、丛林中游荡。如果你想活下去，你需要把更多的精力放在潜在的威胁、危险、可怕的事情上，而不是去欣赏日落、美丽的浆果、美丽的花朵、美丽的蝴蝶。然而，在现代社会中，这不再像过去那样具有保护作用了，现在它实际上只是——我直说吧——一种让人扫兴的打击。太烦人了。太烦人了。当谈到永远对自己拥有的东西不满意时，我们还可以看看诸如攀比之类的事情。我们可以看看诸如无聊之类的事情。
We could, you know, investigate the societal emphasis on materialism. I feel like these are things that we talk about a lot, though, and that we kind of have a grasp on. So I kind of wanted to explore perhaps some different explanations that may not be top of mind for you as you're kind of battling this constant need for more, this constant need to achieve, this constant sense of dissatisfaction with what you have, even if it's what, you know, a
我们还可以（你知道的）调查社会对物质主义的强调。不过，我觉得这些都是我们经常讨论的事情，而且我们对它们也有所了解。所以我更想探讨一些可能不会首先浮现在你脑海中的解释，当你正在与这种对“更多”的不断渴望、对成就的不断追求、对现有东西的不断不满（即使这些东西是你曾经的某个版本的自己做梦都不敢想象的）作斗争时，这些解释或许能给你带来启发。
path diversion of yourself could only have ever dreamed of. So we are going to take a short break, but when we return, let's talk the consequences of this. Let's also talk the solution, because it's probably a little bit different to what you're expecting. Stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalation. available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that
所以我们要休息一下，但当我们回来时，让我们谈谈这带来的后果。让我们也谈谈解决方案，因为它可能和你预期的有点不同。请收听《2%》。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信
seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What? The hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast.
种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题其实都是压力导致的。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更幸福、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》（TWO percent）。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《The Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的霹雳可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我很乐意在某天谈论可卡因，只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二次讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的线索了。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们现在也把艾滋病摆上桌面了。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardaway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐之中
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负之争。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同信任层面的问题。我希望你纯粹是因为想做一个好人而去这样做。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，由我基尔·盖恩斯带你进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开免费的IHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德发现自己处于一场寻子丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显破绽。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。“你在这个特定测试上做过两次手脚，对吧？”“我在测试上做过一次手脚。”这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。“我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。”
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So what exactly are the consequences of this, if it isn't already obvious? Well, the first big one is that, well, obviously you're unhappy all the time, which, you know, isn't really great. It's not how we want to live our lives. The second, though, is extreme guilt.
随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被大陪审团以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。那么，如果这还不算显而易见的话，这一切的后果到底是什么呢？好吧，第一个重大后果是，很显然你一直很不开心，你知道的，这其实不太好。这不是我们想要的生活方式。然而，第二个后果是极端的内疚。
Guilt around the fact that you are unhappy without being able to change the fact that you're unhappy because you feel too guilty about it. Now, I think this is especially the case if you can recognize that actually you do have quite a lot and that there is a lot for you to be grateful for and, you know, you have all these things that people themselves admire and are seeking, but you just can't feel good about it. That's a hard one because rationally you know you have a reason to be happy, but somewhere deep down you can't be. And that's going to create these sensations of frustration with yourself. but also the sense that like I'm not grateful enough.
因为你不开心而感到内疚，同时又无法改变你不开心的事实，因为你对此感到太内疚了。现在，我认为这种情况尤其会发生在你能认识到自己其实拥有很多、有很多值得感恩的事物时，你知道的，你拥有所有那些别人也在羡慕和追求的东西，但你就是无法为此感到高兴。这是一件很难受的事，因为理性上你知道自己有理由快乐，但在内心深处的某个地方，你就是快乐不起来。这会让你对自己产生挫败感，
And so I must be a bad person. I must be a bad person for not being able to appreciate this. I think sometimes as well I have this sense that if I don't feel incredibly grateful and happy about what I have, somehow that's going to mean it's taken away from me. Kind of like I'm an ungrateful child. I don't know. I don't know if anyone else feels this way, but I remember being a kid and opening like, like a present at Christmas and I was like, oh, what is this? And I was like not grateful for it. And
同时也会有一种“我不够感恩”的感觉。因此我一定是个坏人。我无法欣赏这一切，我一定是个坏人。我觉得有时我也有这种感觉：如果我对拥有的东西没有感到难以置信的感激和快乐，不知何故，这意味着它会被从我身边夺走。有点像我是个忘恩负义的孩子。我不知道。我不知道其他人是否有这种感觉，但我记得小时候在圣诞节打开礼物时，我曾说：“哦，这是什么？”我当时对它并不感激，然后
like my granddad took it away. It was like, well, if you're not grateful for things, they, like, you don't deserve them. And now as an adult, I'm like, wow, that really stuck with me. Like, if I don't feel happy about everything I have, I feel extreme guilt because I know someone is doing it a whole lot worse. But also then I feel a lot of fear that it's somehow this like cosmic power is going to come down and take it away from me. You know, God, the universe, something. It also results in a lot of burnout. And perfectionism, procrastination,
我爷爷把它拿走了。就好像，“如果你对事物不感恩，它们——就像你根本不配拥有它们一样。”现在作为成年人，我觉得：哇，那段经历真的深深印在我的脑海里了。如果我对拥有的每一件事都感到不高兴，我就会感到极度的内疚，因为我知道有些人的处境要糟糕得多。但与此同时，我也感到非常恐惧，担心某种宇宙力量会突然降临并把它从我身边夺走。你知道的，上帝、宇宙，某种神秘力量。这也导致了大量的职业倦怠。还有完美主义、拖延症，
the three horsemen of the productivity apocalypse, if you're constantly pushing yourself for more, if you're constantly erasing the bars, setting a new milestone landmark, setting some new goal, the thing is, is that it's going to start feeling more and more like a race, and it's going to start having a deeper sense of urgency because your happiness is at stake here.
这三个是生产力末日的骑士，如果你不断逼迫自己追求更多，如果你不断提高门槛、设立新的里程碑、设定一些新的目标，问题在于，这开始越来越像是一场赛跑，并且会产生一种更深烈的紧迫感，因为你的幸福此时正悬于一线。
And you are going to push and push and push yourself until something has to give. But for you, even when it does give, it's probably not an option for you to rest. It's not an option for you to re-evaluate because you have tied so much of your life satisfaction to the fulfillment of goals rather than to the experience of existing. And it's something I see a lot of people suffer from. Now, the more you find yourself in the cycle as well, the more pessimistic you actually become about the world. You know, you're constantly raising the bar.
你会不断地逼迫自己、逼迫自己、再逼迫自己，直到某个时刻彻底崩溃。但对你而言，哪怕真的崩溃了，休息大概也不是一个选项。重新评估也不是一个选项，因为你把太多的生活满意度系于目标的实现，而不是系于存在的体验。这是我看到很多人都在遭受的痛苦。而且，你越是陷入这个循环，你其实就会对世界变得越悲观。你知道的，你不断地在提高标准。
Perhaps you are meeting the bar, then of course raising it, but you are achieving certain things and you're still feeling unhappy and you start to then spiral and think, well if this doesn't do it what is if I finally have this thing and this wasn't it
也许你达到了这个标准，然后当然又提高了标准，但你实现了一些事情，却依然感到不开心，于是你开始陷入恶性循环并心想：如果这都行不通，那什么才行？如果我终于得到了这个东西，而这却不是我想要的
at some stage there's not going to be anything more or at some stage there's going to be a goal I can't reach I can't meet does that mean I'm going to be in a perpetual state of misery it's a pretty big question to ask yourself and it's one that's pretty hard to answer and will probably lead to quite a lot of sadness
在某个阶段，将不再会有更多的东西；或者在某个阶段，会出现一个我无法企及、无法实现的目标。难道这意味着我将永远处于痛苦之中吗？这是一个相当大的问题，需要你问问自己，而且这是一个很难回答的问题，大概会带来相当多的悲伤。
So let's talk about the solution. I took you low there. I took you to a low point. Let's take us back to the high point. Gratitude is often the solution people will offer you. And it is a pretty brilliant one. You know, it is strongly and consistently associated with greater happiness. Many studies, including one from, I think it was UC Berkeley,
所以我们来谈谈解决方案。刚才我把你的情绪带到了低谷。我把你带到了一个低谷。让我们回到高点。感恩通常是人们会给你的解决方案。而且它确实是一个相当绝妙的方案。你知道的，它与更高的幸福感有着强烈而持久的许多研究表明，其中包括一项来自——我想是加州大学伯克利分校的研究，
found that gratitude can actually physically alter your brain and neural connections, which is just insanely spectacular. In another study, the same university, University, California, Berkeley, recruited 300 participants and asked one third of them to write gratitude letters, one third to write about their deepest thoughts and feelings, and another they didn't ask them to write anything. And they did find that those who wrote gratitude letters, they were significantly happier four weeks and 12 weeks after this exercise had ended. So those results really do speak for themselves. but I have also found that sometimes I do need to go deeper to get myself out of this funk. It's not to discredit gratitude as an important practice.
发现感恩实际上可以物理性地改变你的大脑和神经连接，这简直疯狂地壮观。在另一项研究中，同一所大学，即加州大学伯克利分校，招募了300名参与者，要求其中三分之一的人写感恩信，三分之一的人写下他们最深处的思想和感受，另外三分之一则没有要求他们写任何东西。他们确实发现，那些写了感恩信的人，在这一练习结束后的四周和十二周里，明显要快乐得多。所以这些结果确实很有说服力。但我也发现，有时我确实需要更深入地挖掘，才能让自己摆脱这种沮丧情绪。这并不是要贬低感恩作为一种重要实践的价值。
And of course, I think that is the first step to addressing this. If it doesn't work, though, what's really helped me get to that next level is actually accepting and in fact celebrating negative emotions as much as I do positive ones, which sounds counterintuitive, but let me give you my word, here, let me promise you it works. And it's the same principle behind acceptance and commitment therapy, a very common kind of therapy, which invites people to open their door to unpleasant feelings instead of feeling trapped by them. Why do we feel so trapped by being unhappy? You know, it doesn't feel great, but really what's, if we were to look that feeling in the eye,
当然，我认为这是解决这个问题的第一步。不过，如果它不管用，真正能帮我达到下一个水平的，其实是接受甚至像对待积极情绪一样庆祝消极情绪，这听起来有点反直觉，但请相信我，我向你保证它确实管用。这与接纳承诺疗法（ACT）背后的原理是一样的，这是一种非常常见的疗法，它邀请人们向不愉快的感受敞开心扉，而不是感到被它们困住。为什么我们对不开心感到如此束手无策呢？你知道的，这感觉并不好，但如果我们真的直视那种感觉，
would it really be able to hurt us? You know, it's kind of counterintuitive, right? Unpleasant emotions equal bad. We run away from unpleasant smells, sights, tastes, but here we're meant to run towards it. Well, yeah, and it works because half the reason unpleasant, uncomfortable emotions feel so bad is because, A, we're scared of them, and that fear makes up more of the unpleasantness than the actual emotion does, and B, when we avoid them, we don't develop the strategies to sit with negative emotions when they do occur, which means that when they do occur, which means that when They break through the internal walls that we put up, which they will eventually. They feel even stronger and worse.
它真的能伤害我们吗？你知道的，这有点反直觉，对吧？不愉快的感情等于坏事。我们会避开不愉快的味道、景象、气味，但在这里我们却要去迎难而上。嗯，是的，而且这很管用，因为那些不愉快、不舒服的感情之所以感觉那么糟糕，有一半的原因是：第一，我们害怕它们，而这种恐惧比实际情绪本身构成了更多的不愉快；第二，当我们逃避它们时，我们就不会培养出在负面情绪发生时与之共存的策略，这意味着当它们真的发生时，这意味着当它们冲破我们设置的内部防线时——它们最终一定会这样做——它们会感觉更加强烈和糟糕。
And that reinforces this initial appraisal and belief that they are bad. Here's the thing, and I'm going to say it again, why do we view not being happy all the time is a terrible thing? You know, sure, it doesn't feel amazing when it's all the time. When it comes to not being able to appreciate hard-earned successes, it is pretty exhausting. But happiness is not the only important emotion. sadness, nostalgia, boredom, confusion, disgust, entrancment, surprise, relief, romance, they are all so beautiful. They're like our mind's children.
这就会强化最初的评估和信念，即它们是坏事。问题是，我要再说一遍，为什么我们把不能一直快乐视作一件糟糕的事呢？你知道的，当然，如果一直不快乐，感觉确实不太美妙。当无法欣赏来之不易的成功时，这就相当令人筋疲力尽了。但幸福并不是唯一重要的情绪。悲伤、怀旧、无聊、困惑、厌恶、着迷、惊讶、释怀、浪漫，它们都如此美丽。它们就像我们心灵的孩子。
They each serve such an important purpose. So I need you to lean into experiencing every emotion. Be curious about it. Think of your life as a very rich tapestry. You know, if you are happy all the time, that would mean that the tapestry is just, just one color. Let's say it's just yellow. That's fine. Yellow is a beautiful color, but we want blues. We want reds, purples, greens, every hue to make it interesting, to make life interesting, to make that tapestry, you know, something that's fun to look at. I have found, and this is the easiest
它们各自都有着如此重要的目的。所以我需要你倾心去体验每一种情绪。对它保持好奇。把你的生活想象成一块非常丰富多彩的挂毯。你知道的，如果你一直都很快乐，那就意味着这块挂毯只有一种颜色。比方说它只有黄色。这很好。黄色是一种美丽的颜色，但我们需要蓝色。我们需要红色、紫色、绿色，每一种色调来让它变得有趣，让生活变得有趣，让那块挂毯，你知道的，看起来赏心悦目。我发现，这也是最简单的方法
way to gain deeper appreciation for the small things, which is really what we're after here, not just the big things, that when you do appreciate and lean into unhappiness, sadness, disappointment, and you really like make it an experience for you, you get better at noticing happiness because all of your energy isn't going towards making sure happiness isn't the only flavor or color. I think that's really, really important here. When we struggle with never being happy with what we have, I think it's because we believe somehow that we need to always be happy, that we need to always feel fulfilled. And that's why we are let down by, you know,
去更深刻地欣赏小事，这其实正是我们在这里所追求的，而不仅仅是大事。当你确实去欣赏并倾心于不快乐、悲伤、失望，并且真正把它们变成你的一种体验时，你会更擅长注意到快乐，因为你的所有精力都没有用来确保快乐不是唯一的风味或颜色。我认为这一点在这里真的、真的很重要。当我们纠结于对自己拥有的东西永远不满足时，我想这是因为我们某种程度上相信我们需要一直快乐，我们需要一直感到充实。这就是为什么我们会被你知道的
the lack of satisfaction that sometimes comes from the big things. Now, I introduced a caveat before about that success hangover we've spoken about. I think this has another kind of cure. And that is to name your enough point. And I want to restate that because I know I mentioned it before, but I want it to have its own segment in this section. before you set a goal, before you decide that something is worthy of achieving or something that you want to work towards, I want you to seriously ask yourself, what would enough look like for you?
这种有时从大事中获得的满足感的缺失所失望。现在，我之前针对我们谈到的那种“成功宿醉”提出了一个注意事项。我认为这还有另一种“解药”。那就是说出你的“知足点”。我想重申这一点，因为我知道我之前提到过，但我希望它在这个板块里拥有独立的一段。在你设定一个目标之前，在你决定某件事值得实现或是你想要努力的方向之前，我希望你认真地问问自己：对你来说，“足够”是什么样子的？
Define it before your brain moves the goalpost. Write it down. Please, for me, what is enough for you? What is enough money? What are enough friends? What is enough? What is enough? in a relationship? What is enough in your career? What is enough just for right now? Like obviously it will evolve as you get older. But at some point I need you to sit and acknowledge that you have come very, very far and that you have achieved many, many beautiful things. A really beautiful exercise for me and it's one that made me so emotional recently with the book and everything was just thinking if I could have a one-on-one conversation with my childhood cell. what would I tell them and what would they just be so ecstatic by and how would they view me
在你的大脑移动球门之前把它定义下来。把它写下来。求求你了，对你来说什么才算够？多少钱才够？多少朋友才算够？什么才算够？在感情中什么才算够？在你的职业生涯中什么才算够？仅仅为了当下，什么才算够？显然，随着你年龄的增长，它会不断演变。但在某个时刻，我需要你坐下来，承认你已经走了非常、非常远，并且你已经取得了许多、许多美好的成就。对我和这本书以及所有事情来说，最近一个让我大为触动的超级美好的练习，就是去想：如果我能和童年的自己进行一次一对一的对话，
and what are the things that they would just never believe even my teenage self there are there is something that you have completed and done and succeeded at that a younger version of you would just be like gobsmacked by keep those small achievements that sometimes we don't even appreciate in the moment at the center of your mind put the them somewhere where you can think about them, read them, view them, because I don't want us to be, I don't want us to be in the game of forgetting because we're constantly trying to push ourselves further. Sometimes I think that there is this fear of being happy because we think that, well, if I was happy, I wouldn't be able to push myself anymore. I think it's particularly common
我会对他们说些什么？他们又会对此感到多么狂喜？他们会如何看待我？
amongst high achievers, people who really push themselves, there's this cruel thing that we've realized at some stage that if you dislike yourself and if you are dissatisfied, perpetually in a state of dissatisfaction, well then you're constantly going to be in a state of trying to get out of that state, right? Like if you are unhappy, if you are trying to prove something, that's great motivation for you. Being happy and content. Well, we think sometimes that would mean that we would become lazy. That's not true.
在取得巨大成就的人群中，在那些真正逼迫自己的人中间，有这样一件残酷的事情：我们在某个阶段意识到，如果你讨厌自己，如果你感到不满，永远处于一种不满意状态中，那么你就会一直处于一种想要摆脱这种状态的努力中，对吧？就像如果你不快乐，如果你在试图证明什么，这对你来说就是很好的动力。而快乐和满足呢？有时我们会认为，那意味着我们会变得懒惰。这不是真的。
I'm going to cite a study that found that people who are more fulfilled, content and satisfied with their life are actually almost 27% more productive in their day-to-day lives. So it's not something to be afraid of. You're not going to lose your motivation. You're not going to lose your efficiency and your productive edge. Another thing that's been very, very helpful for me and for other people that I've spoken to as well when dealing with this happiness conundrum is to start a weird ritual. Instead of constantly focusing on what you could have and what you could achieve,
我要引用一项研究，该研究发现，那些在生活中感到更充实、更满足、更满意的人，在日常生活中实际上要高出将近27%的生产力。所以这不是一件需要害怕的事情。你不会失去动力。你不会失去效率和高产的优势。另一件对我以及我和其他交谈过的人在处理这个“幸福难题”时非常、非常有用的一件事，就是开始一种奇怪的仪式。不要总是专注于你能拥有什么、你能取得什么成就，
start something that has nothing to do with any of those things. I heard about this recently from the author Michael Norton, who wrote the book, The Ritual Effect, and essentially what he says is that when you focus on something other than what you, want or what you have and instead focus on something that you can do and can enjoy, our lives get significantly better. Some of the ideas for a ritual he had, and this is my favorite one, was to do many versions of what you would do on a vacation. So go to the local pool, make yourself like a budget version of that holiday cocktail you
开始一件与所有这些事情完全无关的事。我最近从作家迈克尔·诺顿（Michael Norton）那里听说了这一点，他写了《仪式效应》（The Ritual Effect）这本书，他的核心观点是：当你把注意力从你想要的或你拥有的东西上移开，转而关注你能做的事情和能享受的事情时，我们的生活就会有显著的改善。他提出的关于仪式的几个想法中，这也是我最喜欢的一个，就是去做你在度假时会做的事情的微型版本。比如去当地的游泳池，给自己做一杯你所热爱的
loved, commit to maybe doing a touristy thing in your city each weekend. or you can get into the ritual of hosting an event once a month for friends. I do this. It's amazing. One of my friends I've seen this on TikTok does like a coffee shop in her house once a month. I do like a games art themed night once a month. You know, you just need to get involved in the act of doing rather than achieving. You know who some of the happiest and most content people are in the world? It's those who are grounded in doing rather than having.
那种度假鸡尾酒的预算版，或者承诺每个周末在你的城市里做一件游客会做的事。或者你可以养成每个月为朋友举办一次活动的仪式。我就是这么做的。这太棒了。我看到一个朋友在TikTok上分享说，她每个月在家里办一次咖啡馆。我则是每个月办一次游戏艺术主题之夜。你知道的，你只需要参与“做”的行动，而不是“达成”的成就。你知道世界上最快乐、最满足的人是谁吗？正是那些立足于“做”而不是“拥有”的人。
one group I always think of hobbyists, not professionals, not competitive hobbyists, just hobbyists, people who like bird watching, people who like reading, rock climbers, like, um, what's another one, like cyclists, like those people seem so happy because they just enjoy doing something that gets them out of their mind and that there is very limited competition in, especially if you're just doing it for the joy of doing it for their own sense of love and attachment and excitement with the thing. So if you are struggling with this happiness treadmill, you're not happy with what you have, you're constantly looking for more, I need you to take a step back right now. I need you to take a step back, survey your life.
我总是想起的一个群体是业余爱好者，而不是专业人士，不是那种好胜的业余爱好者，仅仅是业余爱好者，比如喜欢观鸟的人、喜欢阅读的人、攀岩者，还有，嗯，另一个是什么，比如骑行者，这些人看起来是那么快乐，因为他们只是享受做一件事，这能让他们从脑海中抽离出来，而且其中的竞争非常有限，尤其是当你只是为了纯粹的快乐、为了自己对那件事的爱、依恋和兴奋而去这样做时。所以，如果你正在与这种“幸福跑步机”做斗争，对你拥有的东西不满意，不断地寻找更多，我需要你现在退后一步。我需要你退后一步，审视你的生活。
When was last time you did something just for the joy of it? But seriously ask yourself, when was the last time you did something just for the joy of it? when was the last time you looked at your to-do list and said, I'm not going to do any of that. Today, I'm actually going to go and do something fun, something I want to do. Maybe that's your ritual, the day of no to-do lists, a day a week where there is nothing planned.
你上次单纯为了快乐而去做一件事是什么时候？但认真地问问自己，你上次单纯为了快乐而去做一件事是什么时候？你上次看着自己的待办事项清单说“这一切我都不做了”是什么时候？今天，我要去搞点好玩的，做点我想做的事。也许这就是你的仪式：没有待办事项清单的一天，一个星期里有一天什么都没有计划。
You just get to dilly dally, dilly dally and doodle, and explore and experience. Okay, we're going to take another short break, but when we return, I want to talk about some of the amazing, listening listener questions that you guys had on this topic. So stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental
你只需闲逛、闲逛、涂鸦、探索和体验。好了，我们要进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，你们在这个话题上提出的一些精彩的听众问题。所以请锁定频道。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的华而不实且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会作为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。也就是 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcast 上的“Two Percent”，
toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the in-practice and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcast.
或者无论你在哪里收听播客。还记得黛安·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英国（Alex English）。
or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重大，不仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊一聊快克，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把这句话补充完整。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple 上收听《Look Back at It》，
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple,
播客，或者无论你在哪里收听播客。欢迎收听我的新播客《The Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞恩·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。
podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
我们还在追逐，却不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。在2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显漏洞。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
在2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显漏洞。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾篡改过某人的这份特定测试，对吗？我篡改过测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子。
Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，亚美科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, it's time for everyone's favorite segment. Our listener questions. This first question, which I love and which we haven't spoken about very much at all in this topic so far, is what is the impact of consumerism? A huge, huge, huge, point that I'm so glad you brought up so I didn't accidentally miss it. I blame consumerism for quite a bit of this, specifically when it comes to not being happy with obviously material goods. The current climate that we live in, the current society that we live in, is obsessed with quantity and with having more and with displaying wealth for.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。好吧，现在是大家最喜欢的环节。我们的听众提问。这第一个问题，我非常喜欢，而且到目前为止我们在这一主题上几乎没有讨论过，那就是消费主义的影响是什么？这是一个非常非常非常重要的问题，我很高兴你提出来，这样我才没有不小心漏掉。我将很多此类现象归咎于消费主义，特别是当人们对物质商品明显感到不满足时。我们生活的现今气候，我们生活的现今社会，痴迷于数量，痴迷于拥有更多，以及炫耀财富。
through the new shiny object, the new trending item, the new viral item. This is going to maybe upset some people, but oh my gosh, the thing that always frustrates me whenever I'm on Instagram or TikTok is people who are like, you need this viral dress in every single color. You need this new item. Like here's my, you know, insane clothing hall. Let's refresh my apartment for Easter. for spring and go and buy all this new stuff.
通过崭新闪亮的物品，新的潮流单品，新的病毒式传播物品。这可能会惹恼一些人，但天哪，每当我在Instagram或TikTok上看到那些说“你需要这种病毒式传播的裙子，每一种颜色都要有，你需要这个新单品，比如这是我的，你知道的，疯狂的服装大采购，让我们为了复活节、为了春天刷新一下我的公寓，去买所有这些新东西”的人时，总是让我感到沮丧。
Like here is this life-changing product. I'm like, oh my goodness. You don't need that. You don't need these things. Like, I'm sure it makes these people very, very happy. But like we said at the beginning, consuming too much of that content is what can contribute to struggling to be happy with what you have because there's constantly going to be someone who has more.
就像这里有这个改变生活的产品。我心里想，哦天哪。你不需要那个。你不需要这些东西。就像，我确信这会让这些人感到非常非常高兴。但正如我们在开始时所说的那样，消费过多这类内容正是导致难以满足于你所拥有的一切的原因，因为总会有人拥有更多。
And there's also, you know, given that social. media is now a job, this person is trying, and a lot of individuals online are trying to get you to buy these things and trying to sell you something, if not directly, indirectly through themselves as a brand. Let me just say this, we definitely don't need as much as is being sold to us. And if you're not careful enough, you will end up buying into this narrative that having this, you know, item, having this new thing is going to make you happy, leaning to perpetual dissatisfaction. You know, consumer culture is built on the idea that what we currently own or experience isn't enough and that buying something will make us happier. It's how impulse spending, chronic overspending, chronic shopping, addictions occur, its identity and the pursuit of happiness through possessions, equating
而且还有，你知道的，鉴这个人正在努力，而且网上的许多个人都在试图让你买这些东西，并试图向你兜售某种东西，即使不是直接的，也是通过他们自己作为品牌间接地兜售。我只想说：我们绝对不需要被兜售的那么多东西。如果你不够小心，你最终会接受这样一种叙事，即拥有这个，你知道的，物品，拥有这个新东西会让你快乐，从而导致永久的不满。你知道，消费文化建立在这样一种观念之上：我们目前拥有的或经历的还不够，买点东西会让我们更快乐。这就是冲动消费、长期过度消费、长期购物、成瘾发生的原因，它是通过占有来寻找身份认同和幸福感，将
what we have to how we should be feeling. So I think there is definitely a large intersection between, you know, consumerist culture and also dissatisfaction and not being happy with what you have. This next question has to do with body image. So if this is something that you're sensitive to skip ahead a couple of minutes, but how does never being happy with what we have tie into physical appearance? This is a component we haven't spoken about yet, but never being happy with what we have doesn't just come down to achievements or material possessions. It can also come down to how we perceive ourselves and how we perceive our bodies. This is again, I think, symptomatic of the society we live in. The idea of the perfect body is constantly changing.
我们拥有的东西等同于我们的感受。所以我认为，你知道的，消费主义文化与不满以及对现有的一切不满足之间，绝对存在着很大的交集。下一个问题与身体形象有关。因此，如果你对这方面比较敏感，请快进几分钟，但是，为什么永远对我们所拥有的不满足会与外表联系在一起呢？这是我们尚未讨论过的一个组成部分，但永远对我们所拥有的不满足不仅仅归结为成就或物质财富。它还可以归结为我们如何看待自己以及我们如何看待自己的身体。我认为，这再次成为我们生活的社会的症状。完美身材的概念在不断变化，
yet we are expected to mould our appearance into whatever shape, form, size image that is meant to be right now. That's not possible. You know, think about it. Like, you cannot add height, add inches, immediately take off 30 kilos and then put it back on when it comes back in style. Like our bodies are becoming these, you know, becoming just something that is only made to be viewed. and made to be shaped and formed and molded into a trend.
然而，我们却被期望将我们的外表塑造为现在所代表的任何形状、形式、大小和意象。这是不可能的。你知道，想想看。就像，你不能增加身高、增加英寸，立即减掉30公斤，然后在它重新流行时再把它长回来。就像我们的身体正在变成这些，你知道的，变成仅仅是为了被观看而制造的东西，并且被塑造、形成和塑造为一种潮流。
And it's not our fault for buying into it. Because when you meet the trend, it feels like you're doing something right. It feels like you'll be praised more. People will think you're beautiful. Perhaps you'll experience a bit of pretty privilege, some perks. Who doesn't want that? But this is a reminder that, again, your body is not a trend. And if you're struggling with being happy with your appearance,
买账并不是我们的错。因为当你迎合潮流时，感觉就像你在做正确的事情。感觉你会受到更多的赞扬。人们会认为你很美丽。也许你会体验到一点点美丽特权，得到一些好处。谁不想要这个呢？但这提醒我们，再次强调，你的身体不是一种潮流。如果你正在努力对自己的外表感到满意，
and just being happy with and content with where you are now, I think it's time to probably tune out some of those, some of the sources of this lack of satisfaction. I'm just going to say it, unfollow the Kardashians. Please and thank you. They are such a, so representative of this. But also unfollow certain pages, Instagram feeds, TikTok's block content that is going to make you feel like you need to opt into this.
仅仅对你现在的处境感到高兴和满足，我想是时候屏蔽掉其中一些，一些缺乏满足感的来源了。我只想说：取关卡戴珊一家。请，谢谢。他们太典型、太能代表这一点了。但同时也取消关注某些页面、Instagram动态、TikTok屏蔽那些会让你觉得自己需要加入其中的内容。
And remember to add some realism into what you're consuming. Filters and the technology we have nowadays mean that the person who's filming or, you know, displaying this video probably doesn't even look like that themselves. And also, even if they do, someone else's beauty does not mean that you don't have beauty as well. You know, there's not like objectively one flower that is the most beautiful or one dog or one cat or one horse that is the most beautiful. And because they're beautiful, it means that nothing else and no one else and no other option has value. Like there's all or nothing thinking when it comes to beauty, specifically someone else's appearance, can get us into a lot of trouble. Obviously, this, I need a lot more time to talk about this.
并记得在你所消费的内容中加入一些现实感。滤镜和我们今天拥有的技术意味着，正在拍摄或，你知道的，展示这段视频的人可能自己看起来根本不是那个样子的。而且，即使他们是，别人的美丽并不意味着你就不美丽。你知道，并没有客观上最美的一朵花，或者最美的一只狗、一只猫或一匹马。并且因为它们很美丽，就意味着没有别的、没有人、没有其他选择具有价值。就像当涉及到美，特别是别人的外表时，这种非此即彼的思维会给我们带来很多麻烦。显然，这，我需要更多的时间来谈论这个。
But I do think that it's important to point out that this definitely applies. We could even talk about body dysmorphia here, but I've done a whole episode on that. If this specific intersection between never being happy with what you have and physical appearance is calling to you and something you want to hear about, listen to the body dysmorphia episode. All right, this next question, how do I stop treating life as a checklist and feeling like
但我确实认为指出这一点绝对适用是很重要的。我们甚至可以在这里谈论身体变形恐惧症，但我已经就此做过一期节目。如果这种“永远对你所拥有的不满足”与“外表”之间的特定交集正呼唤着你，并且是你想听的内容，请听身体变形恐惧症那一集。好了，下一个问题，我该如何停止把生活当作清单，并觉得
if I'm not ticking things off the list, I am not allowed to be happy? gosh, is this not the biggest question that so many of us face in our 20s? I was talking to someone about this at a book event the other day and I was like, wow, it just feels like every single one of us is running out of time to do the millions of different things that people have told we need to do in our 20s, when actually some of them are not even compatible. It's like, well, you need to do solo travel, you need to solo travel, but you also should have kids before you turn 30. and you need to date around and experience like different kinds of love but also you should have a partner and you need to figure out your career and have a stable career progression but also let loose a little bit
如果我没有在清单上打勾，我就不被允许快乐？天哪，这难道不是我们许多人在20多岁时面临的最大的问题吗？前几天我在一次图书活动上和某人谈论这件事时，我说，哇，感觉我们每个人都在争分夺秒地做人们告诉我们需要在20多岁时做的数百万件不同的事情，而实际上其中一些甚至是不兼容的。就像，嗯，你需要独自旅行，你需要独自旅行，但你在30岁之前也应该有孩子，
the checklist oh my god it's so intense sometimes what i will say is this the best thing you can do for yourself is just to choose something you really want to do and pursue it and to just find a way to incorporate experiences you actually want to have along the way. Don't get too caught up in what everyone else is doing and whether that's going to make you happy. Trust your intuition. There are certain things that probably won't make you happy and that you probably can skip over.
清单，哦天哪，有时真是太强烈了。我要说的是：你能为自己做的最好事情就是选择一件你真正想做的事并去追求它，并在沿途找到一种方法将你真正想有的经历融入其中。不要太纠结于其他人正在做什么，以及这是否会让你快乐。相信你的直觉。有些事情可能不会让你快乐，你可能可以跳过它们。
And for the things that you might actually really think that you'll enjoy, you have time to experience them. Our 20s are not the only decade in which we have time. space, energy, resources to do the things we want to do. In fact, the older we get, we probably will be making more money. We will probably have more flexibility when it comes to checking off some important bucket list items for ourselves. So just because you are not where you are right now, just because you haven't done everything that you've wanted to do this far, doesn't mean it's not going to happen. If you checked everything off the checklist now, before your life has even really
对于那些你可能真的认为自己会喜欢的事情，你有时间去体验它们。20多岁并不是我们拥有做想做的事情的时间、空间、能量、资源的唯一十年。事实上，随着年龄的增长，我们可能会赚更多的钱。当我们需要为自己勾选一些重要的愿望清单项目时，我们可能会拥有更大的灵活性。因此，仅仅因为你现在没有处于你想要的位置，仅仅因为你还没有完成到目前为止你一直想做的一切，并不意味着它不会发生。如果你现在在生活甚至还没有真正开始之前就把清单上的所有事情都勾选完了，
begun. What's their left to do? It's important to actually take your time, appreciate the journey. All right, we have time for one final question. How does never being happy with what we have relate to tall poppy syndrome? Does tall poppy syndrome come into play? So this is an Australian phrase for my non-Australian listeners. It's one of my favorite phrases. Essentially what it means is that the tallest flowers are the ones that are cut down first. When someone is going to make a bouquet, when someone wants some fresh flowers, they're going to choose the ones that stick out. So when it comes to human beings or people, if you are too open and honest and brash with your success and your accomplishments, you're going to be cut down. You're going to stick out
还剩下什么可做的？花时间去享受这个旅程实际上是很重要的。好了，我们还有时间回答最后一个问题。“永远对我们所拥有的不满足”与“高大罂粟花综合征”有什么关系？高大罂粟花综合征会起作用吗？所以，对于非澳大利亚听众来说，这是一个澳大利亚短语。这是我最喜欢的短语之一。本质上它的意思是，最高的花往往是最先被砍掉的花。当有人要制作花束，当有人想要一些新鲜花卉时，他们会选择那些突出的花。因此，对于人类或人来说，如果你对自己的成功和成就过于开放、诚实和鲁莽，你就会被砍倒。你会从人群中脱颖而出，
from the herd, you're going to be taken down for that. It's a huge thing in Australia. It's probably a big thing in other countries that just might have other terms. I think this comes into play with never being happy with what you have because sometimes you're taught to downplay your successes and downplay your achievements to not piss people off. You know, there is a fine line to walk here between humility and also confidence and being like, you know what? I'm a fine line. I'm just a lot. I I really, I am cool and I do cool things and I am proud of myself. Tall poppy syndrome can make you feel like I need to be small for other people's sake, but also to protect myself.
你会因此而被拉下马。这在澳大利亚是一件大事。在其他可能有其他术语的国家可能也是一件大事。我认为这与“永远对我们所拥有的不满足”有关，因为有时你被教导要淡化你的成功和成就，以免惹恼人们。你知道，这里有一条微妙的界限需要把握，既要谦逊，又要自信，表现得像，“你知道吗？我很好，我只是有点多。我真的，我很酷，我做很酷的事情，我为自己感到骄傲。”高大罂粟花综合征会让你觉得为了别人的利益，也为了保护自己，我需要变渺小。
What I say to this is that personal acknowledgement and personal pride in what you're doing goes a long way. I also, and you know what, I'm going to say it, you can brag about yourself. brag a little, it's okay. The people who really support you will be so proud of you. Anytime one of my friends comes with me with good news or what they think is a brag, I'm so freaking pumped for them. Being proud of yourself openly is such a good litmus test for understanding who is really
我对这一点想说的是，对你正在做的事情的个人认可和个人自豪感大有裨益。而且，你知道吗，我要说的是，你可以吹嘘一下自己。稍微吹嘘一下，没关系。真正支持你的人会为你感到骄傲。每当我的朋友带着好消息或他们认为值得吹嘘的事情来找我时，我都为他们感到兴奋不已。公开为自己感到自豪是了解谁才是真正站在你这边的人的极好试金石，
on your side and who sees your achievements and your accomplishments and the cool things you're doing as a win for them because they get to be in your presence. So I don't think it's arrogant to sometimes just say, I work really hard. I do cool stuff. I'm creative. I'm kind. I'm generous. That's not ego. That's confidence. And I think there's time, there's a time and a place for it. And if we always suppress everything and keep it hidden, perhaps we will fall into this dissatisfaction trap or that success void that we were speaking about. Well, my lovely listeners, I think that is truly all we have time for today. We have covered, oh so much, and I hope you enjoyed this episode.
谁将你的成就、你的功绩以及你正在做的酷炫事情视为对他们的胜利，因为他们有机会出现在你身边。所以我认为，有时候只是说“我工作真的很努力。我做很酷的事。我有创意。我很善良。我很慷慨”并不是傲慢。这不是自我，这是自信。我认为，这是有时间和地点的。如果我们总是压抑一切并将其隐藏起来，也许我们会陷入我们刚才谈论的那种不满足的陷阱或成功虚空。好了，我可爱的听众们，我想这真的是我们今天所有的全部时间了。我们讨论了，哦，如此之多，我希望你们喜欢这一集。
Make sure to check out my book, Person in Progress, and check out the companion episode to this episode on Mantra. It's titled, I Allow Myself to Be Happy with What I Have. If you want more affirmations and more inspiration to commit to just being satisfied, satisfied with the little things and with what you've achieved so far. I feel like that episode is going to be amazing for that. If you have further episode suggestions, we are always on the hunt for great ideas.
请务必查看我的书《进度中的人》（Person in Progress），并查看本集关于“咒语”的姊妹篇。它的标题是《我允许自己对所拥有的感到满意》。如果你想要更多的肯定和更多的灵感来承诺仅仅做到满足，对小事情和你到目前为止所取得的成就感到满意。我觉得那一集在这方面会非常棒。如果你有进一步的节目建议，我们一直在寻找好点子。
Feel free to DM me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. We also post a listener question box once a week for our upcoming episodes, which is where we got the questions for today's episode from. So if you want to contribute and hear your question in an episode, an upcoming episode, again make sure you're following me and hey hello if you have made it this far I'm talking to you you are one of the lucky ones our emoji for this week that I want you to drop in the comments
随时在Instagram上私信我，账号是That Psychology Podcast。我们还每周为即将到来的节目发布一次听众提问箱，我们今天节目的问题就是从那里来的。所以，如果你想做出贡献，并在即将到来的节目中听到你的问题，再次提醒确保你关注了我，嘿，你好，如果你已经走到了这一步，我在跟你说话，你是幸运儿之一，我们这周的表情符号，我希望你留在评论中
below if you have made it this far is a broccoli stem I just went grocery shopping before I recorded this episode and the thing on the top of my list was broccoli so you guys are clued in on that drop a broccoli down below if you've made it this far thank you for listening until next time stay safe
如果你已经坚持到了这一步，下面是一个西兰花梗。我在录制这期节目之前刚去杂货店购物，我清单上的第一件事就是西兰花，所以你们都知道了。如果你已经坚持到了这一步，请在下方留下一个西兰花，谢谢收听，下次再见，保持安全，
be kind most importantly, be happy, be gentle to yourself, celebrate your accomplishments, know when enough is enough, and we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean
保持善良，最重要的是，保持快乐，对你自己温柔一点，庆祝你的成就，知道什么时候适可而止，我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难之路》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全但确实需要的坦诚对话，但你是在跟一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士谈论这些。有多少人背负着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，
that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
你就必须这样做，在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艰难之路》。2%。这是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难。你会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人的身份从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。即数字TWO percent，在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that Trust your girlfriends Listen to the girlfriends Trust me babe
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说相信你的女朋友们听女朋友的话相信我，宝贝
On the IHart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts On the look back at it podcast For 1979 That was a big moment for me 84 is big to me I'm Sam J
在IHeart Radio应用程序 苹果播客 或任何你获取播客的地方 在《回看它》播客中 对于1979年 对我来说那是一个重大时刻 84对我来说意义重大 我是萨姆·J
And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a here unpack what went down And try to make sense Of how we survived it With our friends Fellow comedians
我是亚历克斯·英格利希 每一集 我们都会挑选一个年份 剖析当时发生了什么 并试着弄清楚 我们是如何和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员
And favorite offers Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及最喜欢的嘉宾一起度过难关的 就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔在80年代那一期里讲的。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回看它》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是由人类制作的。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。